the United Nations Security Council has
final say on some of the most heated
conflicts the world has ever seen
but not everyone say is equal and that's
been a big problem when the UN was
founded after World War two the goal was
to maintain peace and global order and
the UN Security Council was created to
enforce laws and actions
now while the General Assembly is made
up of 192 member states the Security
Council only has 15 States five of those
are permanent members each with the
power of veto that means the US China
Russia France and the UK can
single-handedly block a Security Council
resolution that would otherwise be
legally binding and considering the fact
that these five members don't always see
eye to eye that often means a lot of
inaction on some of the most urgent
international crises one example Syria
when the UN began calling on the Syrian
government to scale back its attacks in
2011 Russia and China decided to veto
those resolutions why well they
considered the resolutions harmful to
their ally Bashar al-assad those vetoes
kept world leaders from taking any
concrete action to help end the deadly
civil war and when the UN tried to
investigate the crash of the Malaysia
Airlines flight that was shot down over
eastern Ukraine in 2014 Russia stalled
action with a veto Russia also blocked a
resolution that would have urged
countries not to recognize Crimea's
decision to leave Ukraine in fact up
until 1990 the USSR led on the number of
vetoes and since the fall of the Berlin
Wall
Russia has cast its veto vote about 13
times and the United States is no
stranger to the veto either since the
get-go it's shut down 79 votes so what
exactly is the u.s. vetoing mostly
resolutions targeting its allied the
State of Israel that includes
recognizing a Palestinian state taking
action against illegal settlements and
giving expelled Palestinians the right
to return in total there have been two
hundred and sixty three vetoes used to
stop resolutions in their tracks since
1946 the veto was supposed to reward the
countries who carried out the burden of
fighting in World War two
but if those nations didn't have that
power Syria Ukraine and Palestine maybe
very different places so is a time for
the UN Security Council to give up the
veto